Oh
reset finish um
this is a big issue for the scriptor by
the way just because it is a very
character centric piece but at the same
time the world changes frequently and I
was doing some reading I had a huge
epiphany which is pretty cool characters
don't need to have marks even main
characters movies can have arcs it's
more the the world basically rotating
around the character rather than the
character being the one that changing
mysteries are very good examples of this
two mysteries your your perception of
the character changes because the story
itself had an arc the character never
changed there's still the detective it's
the difference between having a
character who goes from who they really
are to how they want to be that's like a
hero versus characters who are who they
want to be now we learn who they really
are so it's my shitty lecture so the
Panda place across the street you know
the villain some people just signed the
lease to move in and that's the whole
Vsauce crew really yeah so we're gonna
have my big YouTube neighbors here in a
bit moving into our red they're moving
on towards Street Dogg all the sauces
yeah all the stuff all their
accessibility that's super funny I'm
sure they will be great for multi
neighbors so this is a challenge to you
Jake and Michael and Erik get some nerf
guns and expect four
you
Oh